ils viennent de grandes écoles et leur
objectif aujourd'hui bien c'est d'aider
les salariés qui sentent cette fracture
entre leurs valeurs et leur travail à
démissionner nous sommes avec Romain
Bouchet vous appartenez vous êtes
co-fondateur de l'association vous
n'êtes pas seul alors romain j'aimerais
qu'on commence par parler un petit peu
de votre parcours parce que vous c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est vous qui le
dites vous aviez le job le plus sexy du
21e siècle c'est ce que vous disiez dans
une lettre ouverte en avril 2021 et puis
vous avez décidé de tout quitter
pourquoi et comment ça s'est passé
alors c'est pas moi non plus qu'il dit
c'est des cadres de la Silicon Valley
qui l'écrivent au départ dans la barre
de Business Review en 2012 à propos du
métier de datacentiste et ils le font
dans un but c'est de répondre leur
idéologie qui a une pour unique horizon
en fait le progrès technique et
évidemment je les cite pour critiquer
cette vision un peu archaïque des choses
et si vous le permettez je vais pas
m'étendre sur mon cas personnel parce
que je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur le mouvement de fond
dont on est en train de discuter et
depuis le début de l'émission que
j'écoute j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une
sorte de confusion entre des des
considérations très individuelles on a
parlé beaucoup de générations
individualiste des co-anxiété de
développement personnel ou de voilà de
parcours individuels qui promet une
vision très libérale de ce qui est en
train de se passer
sur le marché du travail alors que
ce qu'on constate également alors même
si c'est pas majoritaire mais ce qui est
ce qui est très profond c'est que au fil
des mouvements sociaux de ces dernières
années on très nombreux à avoir repris
le diagnostic déjà bien établi il y a 50
ans selon lequel la société industrielle
capitaliste qui est construite en fait
sur l'exploitation des humains des
non-humains et des ressources naturelles
jusqu'à l'éradication des conditions de
vie sur terre et ce constat en fait est
aujourd'hui
au cœur des préoccupations d'un certain
nombre de jeunes
salariés et dès lors qu'on fait ce
constat et qu'on mesure la dimension
nuisible de son travail au quotidien on
n'a pas d'autre choix que le déserter de
déserter la guerre en fait qui est menée
par les multinationales et les états
contre contre le vivant dans notre
collectif si vous n'êtes pas seul on
estime que face à cette urgence les
surdiplômés donc on parlait beaucoup des
bacs plus 5 on le devoir moral de
subvertir leur privilège leur capital
social culturel symbolique et parfois
économique pour se mettre au service
d'une culture de résistance assez
nuisance et qui ne vise pas à ménager le
désastre mais plutôt à y mettre un terme
oui on essayait de brosser un peu un
panorama de cette jeunesse c'est ce que
on observe au fur et à mesure qu'on
avance dans cette émission c'est que
c'est peut-être un caséidoscope et que
bien il y a des différentes jeunesses
avec différentes aspirations donc vous
en l'occurrence et bien vous encouragez
à la désertion avec pour objectif de
participer à l'offensive écologique en
fait depuis le monde professionnel
comment est-ce que vous aidez du coup
des gens qui ont le même type de profil
le même type d'aspiration que vous à
démissionner
déjà je vous remercie d'insister sur le
sur le caractère offensif du terme
désertion qu'on essaye un petit peu de
conserver parce que il s'agit pas d'une
résignation comme on l'entend souvent
aujourd'hui pour des politiciens un
petit peu le les choses mais c'est un
geste politique fort c'est à dire on
vise pas une reconversion on vise pas
une bifurcation vers un travail un job
moins nuisible mais on se prépare un
riposter contre les nuisances d'un
secteur qu'on a bien connu donc comme
Gilles Deleuze mentionnait c'est fuir
mais en fuyant chercher une arme et donc
notre vocation c'est de prêter main
forte à toutes ces personnes les
travailleuses les travailleurs qui
souhaitent attirer l'attention sur le
rôle structurel de leur secteur
d'activité dans le ravage écologique et
social
mais il est vrai qu'on s'adresse
effectivement d'abord au sur diplômés
pour qui on estime que c'est un devoir
moral pour plusieurs raisons c'est que
les cadres d'une part ou un pouvoir de
nuisances bien plus important que les
salariés de la classe populaire ils sont
la courroie de transmission
allez pouvoir entre ceux qui possèdent
en haut et ceux qui produisent en bas et
puis il possède ses filets de sécurité
dont on parlait tout à l'heure le
capital économique social culturel
symbolique
qu'ils peuvent subvertir et qui leur
permettent de rebondir et de faire ce
pas de côté donc la façon dont on aide
les révolter solitaires c'est on les
aide à enquêter sur les nuisances de
leur secteur de leur organisation ou
même de leur poste très précisément
que ce soit directement par des
destructions d'écosystèmes ou de bien
commun ou par la promotion de fausses
solutions technicistes sur leur secteur
d'activité et notre seconde vocation est
effectivement de mettre en réseau ces
personnes c'est deserteuses c'est
déserteur pour procéder à une critique
radicale depuis l'intérieur de la
société industrielle et puis de d'être
aussi une passerelle vers des archipels
de résistance et des modes
d'organisation en dehors des
institutions très rapidement romain
parce qu'on a plus beaucoup de de temps
mais vous avez un discours politique
très structuré est-ce que comment vous
vous considérez à ce que vous considérez
comme un mouvement un peu
révolutionnaire avec une dimension même
politique à terme
aujourd'hui je dirais honnêtement
comment ne pas être révolutionnaire
enfin face à l'ampleur du désastre
pour phraser un ouvrage bien connu des
milieux contestataires toutes les
raisons de faire une révolution sont là
ils n'en manque aucune et toutes les
raisons sont réunies sont réunies mais
ce ne sont pas les raisons qui font les
révolutions effectivement ce sont les
corps et les corps aujourd'hui sont
devant les écrans et ce qu'on pense chez
vous n'êtes pas seul c'est qu'il est
trop tard pour avoir de l'espoir mais ce
qui nous manque aujourd'hui c'est du
courage c'est ce qu'on essaye
d'insuffler en fait au révoltées
solitaire qui sont face isolées aux
nuisances de leur secteur d'activité
[Musique]